hey what's up guys my name is eternal
welcome to episode three of network chat
programming so we created an awesome
label and a um text field for the users
name now we're going to do the same
thing for um let's just place it around
about here for the IP address and the
port so let's call this I guess the
dress and we'll get rid of the text
inside it and I believe this size of
this was what was it it was 165 by 28 so
let's just change that to 165 I hope you
guys can see what I'm doing by the way I
think I'll zoom in but I might forget I
remember everything
okay and let's also do the same for name
salute and finally I think we can copy
and paste yeah we can okay so let's just
place it over here and we'll call this
let's see we'll call it a IP address I
guess just a people I'm can get what it
means I want to be as descriptive as we
can and we might even give examples in a
minute
we'll say let's play this off of it I
feel like it's to do okay let's just
move that down pat down okay this is
sometimes annoying but you can um what
you can do is you can actually manually
if we hit the balance here we can
actually manually put the white I'd like
to say 100 or whatever and move it down
as you can see maybe no yet you might
have to get creative this ah
let's select most components and center
them horizontally so there we go and
we'll do the same thing for the port in
fact I think I might move them down a
bit and you'll see why in a minute here
probably like that yeah I think that's
centered okay that's pretty rad um we'll
do this exact same thing in fact we'll
just probably just copy and paste how to
get rid of scape ah which is probably
copy and paste this and put it about
here I'll be the port and you guys might
want to go through this and actually
make it symmetrical whatever but this is
for demonstration purposes so whatever
okay let's make that a bit smaller
and we're good to go so up a bit what
what the other thing I wanted to do is
actually copy and paste this name stuff
and give an example like we'd probably
her name to that name but over here we
might for example put like example a I
don't know 192.168 does 0.2 or something
as an example of what what it means just
just to just for fun just to make sure
the people them understand we want to
make this pretty pretty nice right why
not and for the port we might put
example like frickin my favorite board I
have one unto I said to always use that
when I programming don't know why I just
do okay
that's pretty swell alright so now that
we've done that all the remains is
pretty much a button so let's I think
that let's just move a bit up we might
even make the window smaller when we're
done with this I don't know I don't know
okay cool sweet so now we'll do is we'll
hit the the J button button and we'll
place a new button here and I will
probably call it um you call it
I guess login I don't know you guys want
to call it login and I'll make the text
capital L and will Center it I think
that looks about right yeah beep button
okay one thing that I might do before I
forget is if you launch this on Windows
it probably look a lot different
well will one look like Mac but what I
mean is it'll Java style and you might
not want that you might want it to look
like window like a normal Windows
application um and this looks pretty
this looks pretty good right here but on
Windows it might not so what I want to
do here is actually set up a UI manager
so what I want to do here is under the
in in the constructor I'm just going to
call you I manager dot set look and feel
all right - UI manager whoops
do to you I managed to get system look
and feel class name okay and what that
will actually do is it
set the look and feel of the form to be
the same as native applications on your
platform okay so it's really quite good
there's a bunch of exceptions here I
this just takes up code so I'm not going
to handle all them all you all you have
to do here is if you have a bunch of
exceptions here if it can be thrown
likewise not found instantiation nail
illegal access and sporting field
exception you have a bunch of that stuff
and you don't want it what you can do is
you have to get rid of all them except
we set one of them and change it to just
exception and obviously exception or all
the other exceptions extend exception so
if you handle exception you're handling
all exceptions possible so that'll um
that'll work out really nicely here but
yeah so what this will do is basically
make sure that it looks look native okay
so it didn't I don't think it change
anything for Mac but on Windows you
should see a big difference between um
between this and if you didn't put it in
there so that's a very important piece
of code well yeah so now what we've got
is pretty much our login form it's
pretty much donate you see how quick
that took if we had done that in friggin
code alone it would have been a lot
we're taking a lot longer I'm gonna go
through all of these and make sure that
yes it says text field I want to change
it to tech support it's because we
copied and pasted stuff change that to
text support in fact change it to change
the txt port this says label port good
okay so label port description for desc
and same thing here put desc
oops not poor desc my bad what is it IP
address desc
um that's about it I guess this is a
button login okay so way so we've just
cleaned up a bit of this stuff and you
can see that how much code that we've
potentially avoided typing which is
freaking brilliant but yeah that's
pretty much it um some things okay this
is weird this kind of weird sometimes it
creates labels up here as you can see
sometimes components or global variables
sometimes they're not like this one for
example not sure how it chooses but um I
don't think most of these need to be
global variables I think the only ones
that need to be global are probably the
text fields
we might be pulling strings from pretty
soon but yeah anyway hope you guys
enjoyed this episode of I almost said
game programming there but no no no this
is network chat programming hope you
guys enjoyed this episode and by the way
if you need a tutorial on how to get the
get stuff to work because um I just kind
of threw you guys in there you might not
be able to do that if you want me to
walk you through how to fully use github
to use this project because what I'm
doing is I'm committing each episode as
a different as a different commit so in
other words what's happening is that
whilst the if you just go if you just
never get into source and blah blah blah
into that normal stuff you'll actually
see the most up-to-date version but if
you want say or on your honor you're on
episode 1 or some reason here you just
want the code from episode 1 then you
can actually access that code directly
because they're separate commits so I'll
show you if you want me to just leave a
comment I'll show you guys how to do
that because that's no problem at all
but yeah anyway I hope you guys enjoyed
this episode if you did please hit that
like button and I'll see you guys next
time goodbye
you